[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN GERRISH:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to this morning session
on test-driven development
for the Android platform.
My name is Jonathan Gerrish and
I'm part of the Mobile Ninjas.
We're a small team
within Google who
are passionate about
software testing.
Can I get a quick show
of hands in the audience?
How many of you are
actually writing tests
as part of your normal
software development practice?
That's fantastic.
OK.
So if you've written
tests for Android before,
you've probably used
some of our tools.
We developed the Android
testing support library,
which includes the
JUnit for test runner
and rules, the Espresso
UI testing framework,
and we're also
active contributors
to Roboelectric, the open source
Android unit testing framework.
So everyone is telling
you to write tests,
but why should you really do it?
It's true that tests
take time to write.
They're adding code
to your code base.
And perhaps you've
been in this situation
before, where your manager or
client has been telling you
that they're slowing you down.
But there's so many compelling
reasons to write tests.
Tests give you rapid
feedback on failures.
So failures that are spotted
earlier on in the development
cycle are far easier to fix
than ones that have gone live.
Secondly, tests give
you a safety net.
With a good suite
of tests, you're
free to refactor,
clean up, and optimize
your code, safe in the
knowledge that you're not going
to break existing behavior.
Tests are really the backbone
of sustainable software
development.
You'll be able to
maintain a stable velocity
throughout the lifetime
of your project,
and you're going to avoid the
boom-bust cycles of crunch
feature time and the
aggregation of technical debt.
So in software testing,
there exists the concept
of the testing pyramid.
And this is made up
of a number of layers.
And each layer brings with it
its own trade-offs that you're
going to have to weigh.
At the lowest layer is the
small tests, or the unit tests.
And these need to be very
fast and highly focused.
That's why we recommend you
run these kind of tests, what
is known as local unit tests.
And these are going to run on
your local desktop machine.
The trade-off you're making
with these kind of tests
is infidelity because
you're not running
on a realistic environment and
you're probably substituting
in a bunch of mocks and fakes.
As we move up the
pyramid, we're now
into the realms of integration
testing and end-to-end testing.
And the key with these kind of
tests is to bring in fidelity.
That's why we
recommend that you run
these kinds of tests on a
real device or an emulator.
These are the
kinds of tests that
are going to tell you that
your software actually works.
However, they are less
focused, so a failure
in one of these kind of tests
might take a little longer
to track down than it
would in a unit test.
And one of the big
trade-offs you're making
is in test execution speed.
Because you're assembling
multiple components,
they all have to be
built and then packaged,
shipped to a device
where the tests are run,
and the results
are collected back.
That's going to take extra time.
There's no single layer
in this testing pyramid
that can suffice, so
what you need to do
is to blend in tests
at each different tier,
leveraging the strengths
of one category
to weigh off the
trade-offs in another.
There's no real hard
and fast rule here,
but Google's own
internal testing experts
recommend the
70-20-10 rule of thumb
as the ratio between small,
medium, and large tests.
Let's take a look
at our workflow.
So with test-driven
development, the idea
is that you start by
writing your tests,
then you implement the code
to make those tests pass.
And then when your tests
are green, you can submit.
Again, a quick show of hands.
Who out there has
test-driven their code,
tried test-driven
development in the past?
OK.
Cool.
We like test-driven
development because it
makes you think about the design
of your application up front.
It gives due
consideration to APIs
and the structure of your code.
With test-driven
development, you're
also going to be writing
less code because you only
write the code necessary
to satisfy your tests.
This will enable you to
release early and often.
As you're constantly
green, you'll
be able to deploy a working
application at a moment's
notice.
If you're following
the test pyramid,
the workflow is going to
look something like this.
First of all, we have a
larger outer iteration
that's concerned with
feature development.
Here, it's driven by a
UI test, and the mantra
with test-driven development
is Red, Green, Refactor.
We start off with
a failing test,
we implement the code
to make that test pass,
and then we refactor.
Inside the larger
iteration are a series
of smaller iterations
and these are
concerned with the unit tests.
Here, you're building
the units required
to make the feature pass.
And again, you use
the same mantra here.
Red, Green, Refactor.
Let's take a look at
an example application.
The feature we're going
to implement today
is the Add Notes flow to a
sample note-taking application.
If we take a look
at our mock-ups,
we can see that we start
on a notes list screen
full of some existing notes.
There's a floating action
button down at the bottom.
And the user will
click this, taking them
onto the new add notes screen.
Here, they can enter a title
and a description for their note
before clicking Save.
The note will be
persisted and then
they'll return back to
their notes list screen,
where they can see
their newly added note,
along with any other notes
that previously existed.
Coming back to our
workflow for a moment,
remember that we start
with a failing UI test.
So let's take a look at how this
test would look using Espresso,
the UI testing framework.
The first step is to click
on the Add Note button.
Then we enter the title and
description and click Save
before returning to
the notes list screen.
And here, we're going to verify
that the note that we just
added actually shows up.
Now remember, with
test-driven development,
we'll not implemented
code just yet.
All we have to do
is implement enough
of the application to satisfy
the specification of our tests.
So an empty activity, and just
the resources that we need,
will suffice.
Once we have that,
we can run our test
and we'll see it'll fail.
Now we have to
implement this feature.
So applications are built
up of many small units.
These are small, highly
focused, specialized components
that do one thing
and they do it well.
Collections of these
small units are then
assembled together so that
their collaborations will
satisfy our feature.
Let's take a moment to summarize
the key characteristics that
make up a good unit test.
As well as the
normal conditions,
you're wanting to test your
failure conditions, invalid
inputs, and boundary conditions.
You're going to end up
writing a lot of unit tests.
Unit tests must always give
you the same result every time.
So avoid depending on
things that might change--
For example, an external server
or the current time of day--
because this is going to bring
flakiness into your unit tests.
Unit tests should exercise one
specific aspect of your code
at a time.
You're wanting to see that
a failure in a unit test
will lead you, very quickly,
to a natural bug in your code.
And when you write
unit tests, avoid
making too many assumptions
on the actual implementation
of your code.
You want your unit
test to test behavior.
That way, you avoid
rewriting your test
when your implementation
is changing.
And one of the most important
aspects of unit tests
is they've got to be fast,
especially because you're
writing so many of them and,
during TDD workflow, running
them rapidly.
It would be terrible
if you were discouraged
from writing tests or
refactoring your code because
of the pain in the execution
time of those tests.
And finally, unit tests
are an excellent source
of documentation and
the way it's constantly
evolving with the
code as it changes,
unlike static documents that
will stagnate over time.
Let's try a unit test for
our Add Notes activity.
This activity is going
to take in user input
and then we're
going to persist it
to local storage on the device.
OK.
So we're going to create
the Add Note activity class,
and this will extend Activity,
which is an Android framework
class.
It has a view which is going
to be inflated with a layout.
The user will enter
their data here.
And then we're going to
persist that note into Android
SharedPreferences mechanism.
It's conceivable that, as
our application evolves,
so did our requirement.
And perhaps our
storage requirements
evolve to persist the
notes onto cloud storage
and we have to build some kind
of a synchronization mechanism
for local storage for
the offline use case.
And in these cases, we see
opportunities for abstraction.
We might, in this
example, see that we
can extract a notes repository.
However, one of the key aspects
of test-driven development
is that we only start by
writing the simplest case first,
and then we iterate.
So we're going to resist the
temptation to do this early.
Let's take a look at a sample
of what an idealized unit
test would look like.
They're generally built
up into three stages.
The first stage
is you're setting
the conditions for
the test, and this
includes preparing
the environment,
setting up your dependencies
with their required state,
and preparing any input data.
Next, we'll exercise the code
under test, before finally,
making assertions on the
results or the state.
I like to clearly separate
each of these three
stages of the test and bring the
pertinent aspects of each test
front and center to make
for a really readable test.
Up until now with
the Android platform,
you're writing your
unit tests using
the mockable jarring
conjunction with a mocking
library, such as Marketo.
And let's take a
look at an example
of a test written with Marketo.
OK.
Wow.
That's a lot of code.
OK.
So because we have so many
interactions with the Android
framework, we're going
to need to provide
stubbing behavior for all of
them in order just to make--
just to satisfy the
execution paths of our test.
And furthermore, because Android
uses a lot of static methods,
we're forced to introduce
a second mocking
library, PowerMock,
that will handle
this special case for us.
And there are also some pretty
bad code [INAUDIBLE] here.
Let's take a look.
You see, we're forced to spy
on the activity on the test
and we're needing to do
this to modify its behavior.
And stubbing it out and
providing some no ops.
So we're moving out of the
realms of black box testing
here.
And finally, at the
end, we're making
assertions about the
implementation details.
And if these change, our test
will need to change, too.
So remembering the
characteristics of a good unit
test, let's take a moment to
score this particular test.
While it is very
focused, we're just
testing the happy path
of our Add Notes flow,
and it's certainly fast because
it's running on the local JVM.
However, we were
making rather a lot
of assumptions about the
implementation in that test.
And with this, if any of
our implementation changes,
it's likely we'll
need to rewrite
that test substantially.
And finally, all that
excess boilerplate stubbing
is really distracting.
It's distracting away
from the key aspects
of the test, the
conditions of the test
that you're trying to document.
Well luckily, there's
a tool that helps
address some of these issues.
So introducing Roboelectric.
Roboelectric is an
Android unit testing
tool that's open sourced that
we are actively contributing to.
And to tell you
more about how you
can write great tests
with Roboelectric,
I'm going to hand you over
to Christian Williams,
the original author
of Roboelectric.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN WILLIAMS:
Thanks, Jonathan.
It's awesome to see
so many people who are
into Android testing and TDD.
Yeah, Roboelectric is this
scrappy little open source
project that I started
hacking on back
in the early days
of Android Testing
because I was just super annoyed
at how long it took to deploy
and run tests on an emulator.
And it's kind of
been a side project
of a bunch of different
people until last year, when
I had the privilege of joining
my friend Jonathan at Google,
where he was already working,
on improving Roboelectric
for Google's own
internal test suites.
And since then, we've been
really beefing up Roboelectric
and contributing back to
the open source project.
Today, Roboelectric isn't
an officially supported part
of the Android testing
platform, but we
found that, when
it's used correctly,
it can be a really useful
part of your testing strategy.
And I'm going to show you
a little bit about how
you can do that, too.
Let's go back to
our notes unit test
and see how we might approach
it with Roboelectric.
Since Roboelectric runs
as a local unit test,
it'll still be running
on your workstation,
not on an emulator.
But Roboelectric provides
a little Android sandbox
next to your test, where the
actual SDK code is running.
You'll have access to your
activities, your layouts,
and views, and resources.
And you can generally just
call most Android methods
and they'll kind of
work like you'd expect.
There are parts of
the Android framework
that rely on native code or
collective hardware or interact
with external system services.
So for that, Roboelectric
provides a sort of test stubble
that we call Shadows.
And those provide
alternative limitations
of that code that's
appropriate for unit testing.
Remember that test that we just
saw that had 20 lines of code,
of mock set-up code?
Let's see how that
looks in Roboelectric.
That's a lot less.
We've gotten rid of
all the boilerplate.
The test is about half the
size and much more concise.
We're not forced to think about
the implementation details
as we're writing the
test, which is quite nice.
Roboelectric is going to
set up the application
according to your manifest.
And if we were asking it
to set up our activity,
it runs it through the
appropriate life cycle
to get it into the right state.
Inflates views, all that stuff
that we expect on a device.
So we can just interact with
it as if you're on a device.
So we add some text to
some fields, click on it,
and assert that it adds
a note to the repository.
Now, notice that
we're not actually
going as far as the UI test that
we wrote at the very beginning.
We're not asserting
that the new note
appears on the view screen.
That would be the job
of another unit test.
Now, I mentioned
Roboelectric's shadows.
They actually give
extended testing
APIs to some
Android classes that
let us query internal
state and sometimes change
their behavior.
In this example, we were
asking the application
if any of our activities
requested that an intent be
launched during the test.
We could use that to
assert that, after saving
the note to the
repository, we're
going to go to the
View Notes activity.
Similar testing APIs exist for
simulating hardware responses
or external services,
things like that.
At this point, we have
a failing unit test.
And now we get to--
we're ready for the easy part,
writing the production code.
In the spirit of
TDD, we're only going
to write exactly as much as is
needed to make the test pass.
No more, no speculative coding.
So we inflate a layout,
attach a click handler,
and when the click
happens, we fade a note
and add it to the repository.
Now we can run the
test, see it pass.
If there's some improvement
we can make to the code,
we'll go back and refactor,
and then we repeat.
This is where you
get the thoroughness.
And Roboelectric is
super handy for this
because it gives you
nice, fast test runs.
You can get into a comfy cycle.
We want to not just test
the happy path here.
We're going to test all the
different cases that our code
is likely to encounter.
So for example, input validation
and external conditions
like the network being
down and stuff like that.
Roboelectric can also help with
simulating device conditions
that you'll encounter.
For example, you can
specify qualifiers
that the test should run with.
Here, we're saying a certain
screen size and orientation,
which might change
the layout a bit.
You can ask Roboelectric to run
your test under a specific SDK.
So we'll say Jelly Bean here.
And it actually uses of the
SDK code from that version.
And you can also
tell Roboelectric,
I want to run this
test under every SDK
that you support, or
some range of them
that you're interested in.
And we support Jelly
Bean through O right now.
At Google, we rely really
heavily on Roboelectric
and we're investing
in making it better.
We've got dozens
of apps, including
these, that have
hundreds of thousands
of unit tests
running internally.
So it's well battle-tested.
And we've also recently started
running the Android CTS, which
is the official Android test
suite against Roboelectric.
And we're about 70% passing
right now, getting better
with every release.
So if you used
Roboelectric in the past
and found that
it's come up short,
or if you're stuck
in an old version,
I definitely recommend that
you get up to the latest
because it's come a long way.
We've been working
on reducing friction
in integrating Roboelectric
with the Android tool chain.
It works now very well with
Android Studio, with Gradle.
And we've got support for
Bazel, Google's own open source
build system coming soon.
Roboelectric isn't a
one-size-fits-all testing tool.
It's fast, but it's not
100% identical to Android
in every way, so you want
to use it judiciously.
As I said before, avoid
writing unit tests that link
multiple activities together.
That's not so much a unit test.
That's much better for Espresso.
If you find yourself dealing
with multiple threads,
synchronization
issues, stuff like
that, you're also probably not
writing a unit tests, so not
good for electric.
And particularly, avoid
using Roboelectric
to test your integration
with Android APIs and things
like Google Play services.
You really need to have
higher-level tests to give you
confidence that that's working.
So now that we've got
some passing unit tests,
I'm going to hand you over
to my colleague, Stefan
to talk about higher
level testing.
[APPLAUSE]
STEFAN: Thank you, Christian.
Let's go back to our
developer workflow diagram.
At this point, we hopefully
have a ton of unit tests
and they thoroughly test
all our business logic.
But let's switch gears and
try to see how we can actually
write some integration tests to
see how these units integrate,
and how they actually
integrate with Android
and how they run in
a real environment.
On Android, these tests
are usually referred to
as instrumentation tests.
And I'm pretty sure most of you
have written an instrumentation
test before.
And even though they look
super simple on the surface,
there's actually a lot
going on under the hood,
if you think about it.
You have to compile
the code, you
have to process
your resources, you
have to bring up a full system
image and then run your test.
And there's a lot of things
that go on on various levels
of the Android stack.
So these tests give
you high fidelity,
but as John was
mentioning, they come
at a cost, which
is they are slower
and sometimes, they're
more flaky than unit tests.
So let's actually
see how this works
in your day-to-day
development flow.
Let's say you're
an Android Studio.
You've just written
your new Espresso test
and you hit the Run
button to run the test.
So the first thing that
Android Studio is going to do
is it's going to install
two APKs for you, the test
APK and the app on your test.
Now, the test APK contains
Android JUnit Runner,
it contains the test cases,
and your test manifest.
And then, in order
to run the test,
Android Studio calls, under the
hood, ADB Shell AM Instrument.
And then Android JUnit Runner
will use instrumentation
to control your
app on your test.
What is instrumentation?
I think you guys may
have noticed this.
It's a top-level tag in your
manifest, and why is that?
Instrumentation is
actually something
that's used deeply inside
the Android framework,
and it's used to control the
lifecycle of your activities,
for instance.
So if you think about it, it's
a perfect interception point
that we can use to
inject the test runner.
And that's why Android JUnit
Runner is nothing more or less
than instrumentation.
Let's go a little
bit deeper and see
what happens when Android
Studio actually runs your test.
It runs ADB Shell
AM Instrument, which
will end up calling out
to Activity Manager.
Activity manager will
then call, at one point,
onCreate on your
instrumentation.
Now that we know that
Android JUnit Runner is
our instrumentation,
at this point,
it will call onCreate
on the runner.
And then the runner is going
to do a few things for you.
It's going to collect
all your tests.
Then it's going to run all
these tests sequentially
and then it's reporting
back the results.
One thing to note here is
that Android JUnit runner--
and you may have noticed this--
runs in the same process
than your application.
And more importantly,
if you usually
use Android JUnit Runner,
it runs all the tests
in one single
instrumentation invocation.
Android JUnit runner is
heavily used inside Google.
We run billions of
tests each month
using Android JUnit runner.
And while doing so, we saw
some challenges that we faced
and that we had to solve.
One thing that we see
a lot is Shared State.
And I'm not talking about
the kind of shared state
that you control and that
you code in your app.
I'm talking about the shared
state that builds up on memory,
builds up on disk, and
makes your tests fail
for no reason or
unpredictable conditions.
And this, among other
things, will, at one point,
lead to crashes.
But in the previous module
that I just showed you,
if one of your tests crashes
your instrumentation,
it will take the whole
app process with it
and all the subsequent
tests will not run anymore.
And this is obviously a
problem for large test suites.
Similarly, if you
think about debugging,
if you run a couple of thousand
tests in one invocation,
just think about
what your lock head
will look like when you have
to go through it for debugging.
So that's why inside
of Google, we have
taken a different approach.
Inside of Google,
every test method
runs in its own
instrumentation and location.
Now, you can do
this today, right?
You can make multiple ADB calls.
You can use a runner arc and
maintain your custom script.
But the problem is
it might not really
integrate well with your
development environment.
That's why, today, I'm happy
to announce the Android Test
Orchestrator.
And the Android
Test Orchestrator
is a way that allows you to
run tests like we do in Google.
It's a service APK that
runs in the background
and runs its test in a single
instrumentation invocation.
And this, obviously,
has benefits, right?
There's no shared state anymore.
And in fact, the Android
Test Orchestrator
runs PM clear before
it runs its tests.
More so, crashes are
now completely isolated
because we have single
instrumentation invocations.
If a crash happens, all
the subsequent tests
will still run.
And similarly, for debugging,
all the debugging information
that you collect and
pull off the device
is now scoped to
a particular test.
This is great and we benefit a
lot from it inside of Google.
Let's see how it actually works.
On top of installing the
test APK and on our tests,
what we do now is we install
a third APK on our device,
and it's a service APK running
in the background containing
the orchestrator.
And then, instead of running
multiple ATB commands,
we run a single ATB command.
But we don't instrument
the app under test.
We instrument the
orchestrator directly.
And then the
orchestrator is going
to do all its work
on the device.
So it's going to use Android
JUnit Runner to collect
your tests, but then
it's going to run
each of those tests
in its own invocation.
And it's amazing and I'm pretty
sure you will like this a lot.
And it will be available in the
next Android Testing Support
library release.
And more importantly,
we will have integration
with Android Studio.
It will be available in
Gradle and we will also
have integration
with Firebase Test
Lab coming later this year.
Now that we know
how to run our test,
let's actually look at how we
can write these integration
tests.
And usually, if you write a
[INAUDIBLE] test on Android,
you're using the Espresso
testing framework.
And as you can see, espresso
has this nice and simple API.
And it actually
works pretty simple.
What it does is you
give us a view matcher
and we find a view
in the hierarchy that
matches that matcher.
And then, we either
perform a view action
or check a view assertion.
And because this
API is so simple,
it's the perfect tool, too,
for fast TDD prototyping
of UI tests.
But in order to provide
you such a simple API,
there's a lot of things that
need to go on under the hood.
So let's actually look
at how Espresso works.
So when you call onView
and give us your matcher,
the first thing that
we're going to do
is we're going to create a
view interaction for you.
And then the next
thing is we make sure
that your app is in
an idling, sane state
before we are ready
to interact with it.
And you can think of it, this
is at the core of Espresso.
And Espresso is well-known for
its synchronization guarantees.
And the way we do it
is we loop the message
queue until there
are no messages
for a reasonable amount of time.
We look at all your
idling resources
and make sure they're idle.
And we also look at Async
Tasks to make sure there's
no background work running.
And only if we know
that your app is
in a sane and stable state
and we're ready to interact,
we're going to move on.
And then we're going to
traverse the view hierarchy
and find the view that
matches your matcher.
And once we have
the view, we're then
going to perform a view
action or a view assertion.
And this is great.
So now let's circle
back to the test
that we showed you
in the beginning
and have a closer look now that
we know how Espresso works.
So in the first line,
as you may remember,
we tried to click on
the Add Note button.
And here, we're just going to
use a with ID matcher, which
is a simple matcher that is
matching a view in the view
hierarchy according to its ID.
The next thing we want to do
is we want to click on the View
and we use a Click
View action for this.
Now, where it gets
interesting is the next line.
Because on this line, we want to
type the title and description.
And we want to use a type
text action for that.
But here, all the espresso
synchronization guarantees
will kick in and only
if we know that we
are ready to interact
with your application,
we're going to invoke
the type test action.
And this is great
because it frees you
from adding
additional boilerplate
code and additional
slipping code to your test.
So similarly, we're
going to save the note
and then we're going to verify
that it's displayed on screen.
And this is great.
Now we know how
Espresso works and we
know how it's a great tool to
do test-driven development.
And now I'm going to
hand it over to Nick
to talk a little bit more on how
you can improve your UI tests
and how to improve your large
and medium testing strategy.
[APPLAUSE]
NICK KOROSTELEV:
Thank you, Stephan.
So One good attribute
of a UI test
is a test that never sleeps.
So let's go back to our
example to illustrate
this point a little bit further.
In our example, as
you remember, we
have a note that we
save into memory,
which is pretty fast
and pretty reliable.
However, in reality,
as your app grows,
you probably want extend
this functionality
and save your note to the cloud
or Google Drive, for example.
So when running our
large end-to-end test,
we want to use a
real environment
where we hit the real server.
And depending on your
network connection,
this may take a long
time, so you probably
want to do is in the background.
Now the problem is that
Espresso synchronization is not
aware of any of your
long-running tasks.
This is somewhere where
developers would probably
do something as ugly as putting
a thread sleep in their code.
But with Espresso, it
is not actually required
because you can write an
Idling Resource, where
an idling resource is a
simple interface for you
as a developer to
implement to teach Espresso
synchronization of any of your
custom, long-running tasks
of your app.
So with this Idling Resource, we
made our large end-to-end test
more reliable.
So let's see how we can add
some more medium-sized tests
to your test suite.
So for a medium-sized
test, we want
to keep them small and focused
on a single UI component, where
a single UI component may be
a specific view, fragment,
or an activity.
So let's go back to
our example to see
how we can isolate our
large end-to-end to more
isolated components.
Here in this example,
again, you may have noticed
that there are two activities.
The List activity on
the left and the Add
Note activity on the right.
So until now, we wrote
a large end-to-end test
that gives us a
lot of confidence
because it touches
upon a lot of your code
in your app, which is great
for large end-to-end tests,
but it's not so great for
an iterative test-driven
development cycle.
So let's see how we
can isolate these
and have isolated tests for
each activity in isolation.
To isolate the left-hand
side, the List activity,
we can use Espresso Intent,
where Espresso Intent is
a simple API that
allows you to intercept
any of your ongoing intents,
verify their content,
and provide back a
mock activity result.
Great.
Let's see how that API
actually looks like.
So as you can see, it's
very straightforward.
You have an intent matcher that
will match your growing intent,
and you can provide a version
of your activity result
back to the caller.
OK.
Let's use this API to write
our first isolated test.
In this test, you can
see, on the first line,
we do exactly that.
We intercept our
content and we provide
a stub version of
our activity result.
Now, on the second
line, when we perform
Click, instead of
starting a new activity,
Espresso will
intercept this intent
and provide a Stub Activity
result, which we can then
use on the last line to
verify that our UI was updated
accordingly.
Now we have an isolated test.
OK.
So let's go back to
our example and see
how we can isolate the
second part, right?
So when you usually
write tests, you
end up in a position
where you may
have some external
dependencies in play that
are outside of your control.
In our example, as
I showed before,
we have a note that we save
and it hits the real server.
Now even though we have
another resource now
that makes it more
reliable, your test
can still fail
because your server
may crash for some reason.
So your task will fail.
So wouldn't it be better if we
completely isolate ourselves
from these conditions
and run our tests
in a hermetic environment?
This will not only make
your test run much faster,
but it will also
eliminate any flakiness.
And beyond this
specific example,
you further want
to isolate yourself
from any external dependencies.
So for example, you don't want
to test any Android system
UI or any other UI
components that you
don't own because they
probably already tested
and they can also change
without your knowing
so your test will actually fail.
Let's see how our
second isolated
test will look in code.
So the main point here
is that we no longer use
the real server.
Instead, we set up a
hermetic repository.
Now, there's many different
ways of you to do this
and this is just one way.
So then you can use
this hermetic repository
in order to verify that
your note is actually
saved without ever leaving
the context of your app
or hitting the network.
So at this point, if
you think about it,
you have two smaller tests
that are way more reliable
and run much faster.
But at the same time, you
maintain the same amount
of test coverage as your
large end-to-end test.
And this is why we want to
have more of these smaller
isolated tests compared to
the large end-to-end tests we
showed before.
OK.
So at this point, we iterated
through our developer cycle
a few times and we should
see all of our tests
start turning green and we
should be confident to release
our feature.
However, before
we conclude, let's
jump into the
future for a second.
As your app grows
and your team grows,
you continue adding more and
more features to your app.
And you may find
yourself in a position
where you may have UI running
in multiple processes, which
is exactly what
happened at Google.
So if you go to our
Add Notes example,
this may look
something like this.
You have a first activity
that runs in your main process
on the left-hand side.
And now the second activity
will run in a private process.
And in this case, we're
going to call it Add Notes.
So how do we test that?
Well, before Android O, it
wasn't possible to test.
But with Android O, there
is a new instrumentation
attribute that you can use
in order to define which
process you want to instrument.
While instrumenting and
running tests, I guess,
each process, in
isolation, is a great idea
and you should do it, you may
find yourself in a position
where you want to cross-process
boundaries within one test.
So you would probably
want to write an Espresso
test that looks like this.
While this was not only
impossible on a framework level
before Android O, this was also
impossible on Espresso level.
Because in this
specific example,
Espresso is not even aware
of your secondary process,
nor can it maintain any of
the synchronization guarantees
we all know and love.
Today, I'm happy to announce
Multiprocess Espresso support.
Without changing any of your
test code or your app code
this will allow you to
seamlessly interact with UI
across processes, while
maintaining all of us
Espresso synchronization
guarantees.
And it will be available in the
next version of Android Test
Support Library release.
So let's have a quick overview
of how it actually works.
Traditionally, as you
know, in our example,
we start in one
process, where we
have an instance of Android
JUnit Runner and Espresso,
in this case.
Now, if you remember
from our example,
when we click the
Add Note button,
there will be a new activity
and now we have a new process.
So the problem now
is that we have
two processes with two different
instances of Android JUnit
Runner and Espresso, and
they're not aware of each other.
So the first thing
that we want to do
is we want to establish
communication between the two
Android JUnit Runners.
And now that we have
this communication,
we can use it to establish
the communication
to Espresso instances.
And the way we do
that is by having
an ability in the Android JUnit
Runner to register any testing
frameworks, like Espresso,
with Android JUnit Runner.
And then the runner will then
facilitate all the handshaking
required in order to establish
communication between the two
Espresso instances.
Now that the two
Espresso instances
can talk to each
other, it can then
use it in order to enable
cross-process testing
and maintain all the
synchronization guarantees
that we had before.
OK.
With that, we're reaching the
end of our developer workflow
and we showed you all
the tools that you
can use across each
step of the way
in order to make TDD
happen on Android.
And with that said, even if you
don't follow this flow exactly,
hopefully, you know how
to use every single tool
and how to write good tests
in order to bring your app
quality to the next level.
So if you like to write tests
and you want to write and run
tests like we do at Google,
here are some resources
to get you started.
I want to thank
you and I think we
have some time for questions.
And if not, we have office
hours at 3:30 today.
So hopefully, we'll
see you there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]